wir sind nach der Verleihung des
Deutschen webvideopreises die
sensationell war was soll ich auch
anderes sagen auf dem Weg durch
Deutschland und wir das bedeutet jemand
ist bei mir es ist Michael Schulte einer
der erfolgreichsten Musiker auf Youtube
er hat beim deutschen seines Single so
Traveller vorgestellt und ist gut
angekommen an Höhepunkt würde ich sagen
mann ich hoffe doch ja ja richtig klasse
er hat unpluggespielt und ich würde
sagen das war hammer übrigens auch ein
Kino Organist wir hatten Kino Orgel und
der war ziemlich lustiger wird der war
Hammer oder hammer hammer ist dann auch
das Stichwort unser nächster ist der
Hammer es ist nämlich Anke Engelke sie
startet jetzt gerade ihre neue Staffel
Ladykracher und darüber werden wir mit
ihr sprechen und wir werden sprechen
Nein beantworten eure Fragen allerdings
die besten Chancen haben natürlich die
Kreativen die müssen
Münster wir fahren gerade nach Münster
haben die kreativsten Fragen haben die
besten Chancen ähm das heißt lasst euch
was einfallen die verrücktesten
lustigsten und so weiter Fragen kommen
mit ziemlicher Sicherheit daran einfach
unten in die Kommentarfeld klicken
daneben gibt es einen Link reinklicken
oder hier im Video packe ich einen rein
dann noch den Infotext unten legen lesen
das ist nicht unwichtig und dann kann
eigentlich nichts mehr schief gehen und
auch auf die Kekse die Links im Infotext
klicken und dann würde ich sagen ich
drück die Daumen hoch ich auch ja dann
kann eigentlich nichts mehr schief gehen